les lorrains
mais si vous la croisez un jour quand il
peut aller comme ça ça le rend plus
humain la wii est prise de bon dit comme
ça ça peut paraître ridicule mais il
faut le savoir ça la met dans des états
de nerfs pas possible la possibilité de
friser regarder sa réaction en voyant
une simple bouteille
hier vous qui la connaissait bien le
freeze touche écroule s'écroule parce
que prise et ça me défrise allez on va
enchaîner enfin on n'oubliera pour la
pour la vie pour les interviews de la
semaine prochaine nous n'oublierons pas
oublier en tout cas c'est bon à savoir
si vous voulez agressé isabelle
morini-bosc dans la rue et de la menacer
avec une arme n'a scellé avec inscrit
j'espère qu'une bombe à eau m23 de carte
bleue direct afin de cette bataille
d'eau isabelle a voulu se venger de
l'homme dans la range est en phase qui
avait jeté du liquide c'est gratuit mais
moi ça m'a fait rire tu vas pas celle à
cacher rien fait moi j'y crois pas
je vous dis ils sont tous pareils dans
cette équipe non franchement jouer et je
vous donnais du mérite mais vous avez du
mal de supporters si j'arrive je vais
vous faire une confidence à vous public
parfois pendant les pubs syrie vient
nous remonter les bretelles
car on a parlé les uns sur les autres
enfin ce qu on a fait trop long parce
qu'on a osé le regarder droit dans les
yeux je veux demander pourquoi il nous
recadrer autant hebinger un début de
réponse
et non ça fait trop longs leur d'or aux
inventions
alors je dis en face à prades ils sont
trop longs leurs explications offertes
le courroux le court tacatac des
producteurs un peu
écoutez j'ai coustal à 1015 en voilà et
j'écoute ces conseillant alors il n'a
pas dit n'a pas complètement tort
jean michel est une petite balance oui
c'est non c'est étonnant de la part d'un
homme qui disait il ya à peine deux
jours on va pas dire qu'on a un peu on
sème on est des frérots on s'entraîne
dans la série aimons nous soyons tous
des frérots un moment d'affection entre
jean michel et isabelle morini bosc
alors on et redonne un peu de moi
ses parents
ils sont méchants psg il a rien dit il
est dit qu'il aimait bien oui juste un
peu marre de tes dans ce même s'il a son
explication
je commence ma part les gens
et la namibie est ce qu'on veut pas dire
qu'on a un peu on sème on est
défraieront sont très faibles
mais trop c'est aussi partager des
moments intimes manger en plus
j'espère
les gouttes les de mdcu jours la classe
toujours la classe c'est vrai mais celle
qui continuera à chercher l'amour en
alors si vous êtes intéressés voilà ce
qu'ils cherchent qu'à trois jolies drôle
et riche non ce pari
elle est pas riche ces problèmes [ __ ]
ça passe et c'est tout ce qu'elle a
retenu des bizarres c'est jean-michel
n'est pas le seul à chercher il ya aussi
isabelle qui est ouverte à l'amour c'est
la réalité
j'ai découvert l'amour oui oui j'espère
j'avais construit et bien cette part est
ouverte à la cathédrale les invités
c'est sans fioritures méfiez-vous pierre
c'est ce qui intéresse les hommes
l'émission est lent et mou
sentimentalement lui a alors on le dit
ou pas je voudrais qu'on accueille tout
de suite grégoire
plus jamais la regarder pareil là la
beauté intérieure chez isabelle on peut
la visiter
fédérer alors publié ce moment
embarrassant on va faire une petite
pause camille combal
car lundi jo gages à m camille dans les
cas tiers eh ben je suis désolé mais
j'ai rien trouvé et par fait faillite
c'est une machine de guerre
ah oui mais pas rigoureux professionnel
au niveau de l'hygiène ah ouais j'en ai
vu des gens propres mais lui c'est le
seul mec qui se lave les mains 846 fois
par jour et même pendant sa rubrique
mais qu'il avance et l'image
il se lève les mains soyez très propre
soyez beaucoup de rilhac regardez bien
12 alain souchon en interview sur tf1 il
va bien et vous avez voulu monter les
marches du palais des festivals pour
présenter votre film dans chaque année
et c'est à ce moment là que je me suis
rendu compte qu'ils étaient la femme de
ma vie
harry potter et l usure excessive avec
cette histoire est inspirée de faits
réels
elle est confinée pour venir beaucoup de
gens nous ont demandé pourquoi nous
avions pris des vacances en décembre
et bien tout simplement car nous étions
fatigués et ça commençait à se voir lors
de notre dernière émission avant les
congés il est belle avait été déguisé en
sapin de noël
oui oui pire ça arrive dans touche pas à
mon poste de la garde et d'ailleurs donc
c'est quelque chose d'assez courant par
contre que nous n'avions jamais vu c'est
un sapin qui dort pendant les magnétos
des vitraux des cours
du coup un punisher prochain le tournoi